estamos multiplicando esta matriz a por
el vector w y nos preguntan que es por w
entonces vamos a pensar en lo siguiente
así que tenemos la matriz a por el
vector w y solo como un recordatorio a w
lo voy a escribir en negritas por acá a
w
wv y puedo escribirlo ya sea como un
vector o puedo ponerlo en negritas
también wv en minúsculas para el vector
mayúsculas para la matriz esto es
exactamente lo mismo que la matriz a por
el vector w por el lector
wv director w lo pongo el mismo color el
vector w lo cual es lo mismo
esta es la matriz a así que a es 03 55
52 por el vector w
w el vector es el vector 343 así que
tenemos una matriz una matriz con dos
renglones y tres columnas entonces es
una matriz de dos por tres
por el vector y este es un vector
columna es de tres renglones y una
columna así que puedes verlo como una
matriz de tres por uno y entonces
realizar esta operación es simplemente
multiplicar dos matrices puedes ver este
vector columna como una matriz de tres
por uno y la única manera en la que la
multiplicación de matrices está definida
es si el número de columnas en esta
matriz es igual al de renglones en esta
otra matriz y vemos que este es el caso
ok ahora esta matriz la matriz a tiene
tres columnas 1 2 3 y el vector w tiene
exactamente 3 renglones entonces la
multiplicación de matrices o de matriz
por vector si está definida en este caso
y la manera como lo vamos a hacer vamos
a terminar con una de 2 por 1 va a ser
una matriz de 2 por 1 tendrá dos
renglones y una columna o puedes verlo
como un vector columna donde tienes dos
renglones en la columna
de cualquier manera vamos a pensar en
cómo lo calcularemos así que tendrá dos
en glonass y una columna voy a dejar
mucho espacio para calcular entonces la
entrada de aquí arriba vamos a obtener
la información del renglón la
información del renglón de aquí de
nuestra primera matriz y la información
de la columna solo hay una columna aquí
vamos a obtener la de esta matriz o este
lector como le quieras llamar así que
vamos a tener 0 por 3 0 por tres más 3
por 4 3 por 4 más 5 por 3 5 por 3 y
ahora la segunda entrada va a ser el
segundo renglón aquí literalmente el
producto punto de eso con este vector si
no sabes lo que el producto punto es es
justo lo que voy a hacer tomás cada
término correspondiente toma sus
productos y los demás todo entonces es 5
por 3 5 por 3 más 5 por 4 5 por 4
dos por tres dos por tres y
simplificando un poquito nos va a quedar
acá arriba esto es
cuál es 27
y luego en el segundo término esto es 15
+ 20 6 entonces esto es 35 6 nos da 41
entonces es un vector de columna de dos
renglones 27 41 entonces vamos a poner
eso acá 27 y 41 ponemos 27 y acá ponemos
41 verificamos la respuesta y está
correcta